my kids won't even know what a TV is and  when they do see a TV they'll be like  what do we need this for when we already  have books my kids favorite thing to eat  is gonna be vegetables they're gonna be  like mom we're out of asparagus again  and I'll be like you kids in your  asparagus I'm not gonna be one of those  schedule obsessed parents I'm gonna be  chill and my kids are gonna appreciate  it I am never gonna say that I can't go  out after 10:00 p.m. because I got kids  yeah that's what Red Bull and  babysitter's are for I'll always be on  time  just like now and when my kids are tired  they'll go to bed it's not rocket  science  there's no reason why having a baby  should prevent you from doing Crossfit  when my kid says watch mommy I'm gonna  watch every single time absolutely I  hate it when people are like just a  minute honey that's your kid I will  never leave the house looking less than  put together I'm not even gonna own a  pair of sweatpants I miss being an  expert